and the final announcement in today's
budget takes a first step
madam deputy speaker
for many of the lowest paid in society
there is a hidden tax on work
the universal credit taper withdraw
support as people work more hours
the rate is currently 63
so for every one pound someone earns
their universal credit is reduced by 63p
let us be in no doubt this is a tax on
work
and a high rate of tax at that
organizations
organizations as varied as the trades
union congress the joseph rowntree
foundation the resolution foundation the
center for policy studies and the center
for social justice have all said it is
too high
so
to make sure
work pays
and helps some of the lowest income
families in our country keep more of
their hard-earned money
i have decided to cut this rate
not by one percent not by two percent
but by eight percent
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
this is a tax on working people and we
are cutting it from 63 to 55
the re the rate originally envisaged by
my right honorable friend the member for
chingford
and because i'm also increasing the work
allowances by 500 pounds this is a tax
cut next year worth over 2 billion
pounds nearly two million families will
keep on average an extra thousand pounds
a year
changes like this
normally take effect at the start of the
new tax year in april
but we want to help people right now so
we will introduce this within weeks and
no later than december the 1st
[Music]
[Applause]
let me tell the house what these changes
mean
a single mother of two renting and
working full time on the national living
wage will be better off by around 1 200
pounds
a couple renting a home with their two
children one working full-time the other
working part-time will be better off
every single year by 1 800 pounds
this is a 2 billion tax cut for the
lowest paid workers in our country it
supports working families it helps with
the cost of living and it rewards work
[Applause]